did lebron elbowed him yeah lebron
evolved i feel like he's getting you
guys saw this though right yeah i saw
him do you think he did it on purpose
my question is
yeah here's my question is he is he
on edge because he's taking so much [ __ ]
about the china stuff no watch watch
think this
let me know what you think me oh no he
didn't mean to do that
he got ejected for that james started
yeah
i mean the dude was the dude was so
pissed off he kept coming after him
nah that's on purpose that's not purpose
i don't know he was like you don't know
i thought it was on but that looks on
purpose oh bro that looks like it's on
purpose yeah go back go back
i don't think he meant to cut his eye
like that i think he's just trying to
yeah i think he was just trying to push
them off
yeah that's a [ __ ] hit though like i
don't think his intentions were to like
[ __ ] dudes eye up no but watch watch me
dude it took so many people to hold him
back yeah look at westbrook
westbrook is ready to fight oh bro no
watch he he is again
so watch the there's a big men trying to
get out of here that's a problem all
those look at all the the little white
guys trying to stop them oh they they
start falling because they can't uh they
can't hold them that's a giant man yeah
he's very upset
why uh because he runs back at them look
at him oh my god
who's he trying to get at all of them he
want anybody
westbrook was that look how maddie but
he goes after him one more time
oh really yeah
he breaks free again uh-huh peace man he
was looking at my [ __ ] eye because he
because he because he walks up he goes
all right all right all right i'll leave
i'll leave i'll leave you all right cool
all right it's cool
i'm good i'm good i'm good hold him back
in here
what's lebron james doing here are they
talking are they talking
i don't know i would imagine
that yeah yeah
yeah oh someone got trapped yeah and
then what's look at what's broken yeah
wow
i feel like stewart might beat the [ __ ]
out of lebron look at lebron he's off
i think lebron was trying to be cool
like yo my bad let me see i want to see
if he is
he broke free into the tunnel yeah
you'll see that was the funniest part
when he was like all right
is he trying to go around that's what it
seems like right yeah
my favorite part is that all right i'm
good i'm good i'm good i'm good i'm good
he's wanting to
i can't imagine lebron's very tough uh
i wouldn't he's been famous since he was
12. yeah i don't think he i don't think
he's got fed he's definitely still
competitive though i mean he is but like
yeah it's true i don't think yeah i
don't think he's trying to fight nobody
that guy would have beat the [ __ ] out
lebron
like that guy's so much tougher than
lebron yeah yeah
caught me
angrily you are in every facet i'm not
yeah no i'm not don't say i'm casual why
you keep calling casual like this
because those people yeah he's big and
strong and you do he's so athletic i
don't talk that way he's so happy i
don't talk that way i talk like this no
no i don't i that guy would [ __ ] i'll
fight you now because that guy didn't
grow up like lebron
name the tough guy you
yeah name's the toughest guy you know
he's yeah he's just too much fun you've
been treated like
you know everyone takes care of your
dirty work yeah like you're not gonna be
tough
you're not looking to that guy's hungry
that guy wanted a piece of that guy
worth a billion dollars
i think i think lebron was trying to
just push him off uh
i think yeah i don't think he was i
think you know i don't think lebron was
like i'm gonna [ __ ] see him here and
you go get the [ __ ] off man no i think
he
yeah i think lebron's a really nice guy
yeah he's trying to be cool
now if it was michael jordan jordan
jordan when jordan wouldn't be saying
sorry he'd just be like no well if this
this is the early 90s knowing we got a
jacket yeah yeah
part of the game it was crazy how rough
that game was it was crazy that's how it
should be yeah to be honest like the 90s
was nuts
detroit and stuff they're just beating
the [ __ ] out of those guys